Okay,
we are back.
Let's get uh some stuff on the website,
eh?
does not
not run.
Okay. So, this is uh failing to load
shaders. Obviously,
I have I forgot to write those. [ __ ]
I totally forgot about that, didn't I?
That's kind of bad.
Going to move terraform.
to
top level end
fix tower climb
close seg vault
you got PR I have to do um the shader
for this I forgot that I didn't do the
web version of the shader I will do that
one gigap that's fine as long as you
don't break other stuff in puffer liib
in the process. If it's not touching
other files, that's fine. Like other
than those ends,
you know,
and I can do that right now, man.
Like, I want to get this stuff done. I'm
sick of dealing with this update.
Like, this thing just needs to be done.
Done.
policy. C. So Spencer, one thing that
you should try before you go ham on that
is like if you just throw a linear LSTM
at, it doesn't do anything.
possibly with a one hot encode if you
have one hot data because like I did
that for some other MS like I did that
for snake and stuff and like as long as
you don't feed in one hot data without
one hot encoding it flat actually will
do very well very often and then you can
like trivially just copy the policy in
not saying to use that for everything
but just for like a quick web demo
I don't want people spending forever on
like individual C policies when like
realistically we're just going to have
to come up with a easier way to make our
C policies, right?
I had an idea for that
Discord. I don't know why the Discord
banner keeps breaking as well.
Solid work.
Files changed one.
Oh, 16.
Okay. GPU drive. Terra
CPU binding. That's fine.
Let's see.
H I
for mind for C.
Spacing change. What do you mean a
spacing change?
Okay. I did this to offset it so um that
the target would like render a little
above so it wouldn't clip, but that's
fine.
Oh, okay. I thought I'd made it
transparent, but maybe not.
Okay. Was there a puffer lip spacing
thing?
The heck?
Yeah, that's just weird.
So, let's uh let's see if this gets onto
website.
How big is it? How big is giant? Right?
Like how big is the obs? If it's like
many thousands, that's not going to be
good.
a GPU drive, you'd have to like
massively reduce road points. Um 300 to
400 is fine. Try it with Terra first.
Just literally it's the default policy
within LSTM and just see what it does.
Ah, god damn it. It should not seg fault
when you do that though. It's like it
should at least give you some sort of
error. Sag fold is like the worst
possible thing
back stop in.py
found zero JSON files. What am I
supposed to do with this thing again?
Damn it. Yeah, we need to at least have
one map. Okay. Like for We need to at
least have like one cool map in here by
default. Just literally one like one
cool map by default.
Um and then it should warn you when you
try to train, right? Or whatever that
like, yeah, hey, we need more maps.
or not even worn. It should just crash.
But like it should actually say, "Hey,
download these maps from here.
The difference in like the difference in
number of people who will use this thing
if it like just works versus if it
almost works is going to be very large,
man. It's like the same with all these
ends.
I can tell you that from experience on
neural MMO like one and two. I had stuff
that was way easier to use in
multi-agent RL than anybody else, but it
was still hard. It was just easier than
everyone else's. And it's still like
people wouldn't put in the effort. Like
they'll just they instead of using your
thing that's like easier, they'll go do
some other dumb thing that's like
easested,
you know?
Well, I could do research on neural MMO
and that would be really cool, but I
couldn't figure it out. So, I decided to
do my whole PhD on Atari. Like literally
that.
Also, Eugene's on vacation till the
24th. So, yeah, this thing's going to be
released before then.
Yeah, I the thing is it's not it's not
really that bad for us because we don't
do strict versioning on our
environments. Like there are some RL
libraries where they're really strict
about like oh it has to be you know
versioned so that like results in
published papers will be directly
comparable or whatever. I kind of just
assume nobody's publishing useful papers
and like
it's better to just have the latest
thing be the best thing always
We'll have to just like we'll see if it
works out of the box.
It's easy conversion [ __ ] I just don't
write enough of these.
That looks good. Varying an attribute.
That's roughly what I remember it
looking like.
Really annoying how it's um different
versions. It's one of the main
complaints I have with uh with Rayb.
Like I wish they would just support some
version that works on both.
I think it's you should be able to use
like 3 0 or something. You shouldn't
have to use 1
and then that would be like good enough.
This what it's supposed to look like,
Spencer?
Like the out of the box doesn't look
anywhere near as cool, right? Cuz it's
like
it's basically already done. Got like a
few chunks ripped out of it.
I don't know if this is this curriculum
stuff or what.
Comment out the reset section.
I don't want to screw up the actual
game. Like I cuz I don't want to like I
can change the C not the H. Yeah.
curriculum. Don't worry, it's
experimental. Cool.
Do I go to here
or do maybe to here
Yay.
Oh, what is this, man? Like, it's just a
shadow of where you need to complete
now.
Oh, is this my shader? But like just
it's really low or whatever.
Okay, that's fine.
Little map.
Where are those low poly dozers I sent
you? I might just buy those to load one
of them in.
I think it' look better.
See
if these have like reasonable.
Of course, it's freaking unity.
You don't need to get a pearlin to
pearlin policy for Spencer.
I we we always like too much feature
creep. Just we use this if we can get
like a simple thing that we can at least
load onto the web.
Do it for the thumbnail.
Do what?
Yeah, I think if we like show it like
partially being completed, it'll be
cool.
I have to
cards expired. I have to add.
I think it's going to be on me for
for then after that to like get
to get something reasonable. Any like
aesthetic changes, now would be the time
because I'm basically after this, I'm
just going to get these onto the website
and then I'm going to try to get the
trailer person hired today. I'm
basically just going to go around on
Upwork to find somebody who doesn't seem
like a total [ __ ]
Upwork is kind of a mixed bag. It's like
there's some ridiculously talented
people on there working for like nothing
where it's like you end up just tipping
them the whole price of the order
because it's like what are you doing?
Um, and then there are people that are
just like have absolutely no value
where it's like, dude, you just type
this thing into GPT is all you did.
Writeups are good.
I got to start on that as well. Well, I
have I actually have a few of them ready
to go to be fair.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing. I have to
It's kind of awkward. Like, they don't
let you download your stuff directly.
They make you download them with Unity,
which I think is just really gross.
Yeah, the fact that they don't have a
download button is just disgusting.
It's like they don't want people using
their [ __ ] outside of Unity or whatever,
I guess, which is dumb.
Hey, dear ghost. I'm just trying to get
these assets that I got. Where the heck
is this?
Here we go. See, this is so ridiculous
that they literally they don't let you
download it without getting Unity.
So now I should be able to
there a way to run autotune on 30.
Uh there should be you might have to
just call the function though directly
from vector because we haven't I haven't
messed with that in a while man.
I should actually fix that up. I just
haven't messed with it in a while
because like
we don't need to autotune any of our new
ends because they're so fast, you know.
But you totally can do it if you just
run from vector. Most of the time
though, like picking some multiple of
ends and then double or triple buffering
is going to get you most of the way
there.
Okay, here we go.
Go away, Unity.
Nobody likes you.
Go away.
Doesn't even
There it goes.
Now we go to the program that doesn't
try to do scummy things.
Where's my dozer?
Wait, what?
It said there's a dozer.
There's a really good online viewer.
Like they actually did a pretty good job
with that.
Not it either.
The hell is our model?
Can you look at Envy? Can do. Give me
one second to finish this.
Uh,
driving me crazy.
texture not mapping annoying.
All right, though I will uh I'll look at
end.
You can go ahead link code in Discord.
Yeah, that's good. Um, I do kind of want
to load this dozer in though. So, that's
going to be the main thing. I'll need
the policy
code.
See your code. This is poly time. Yep. I
remember this.
What did you want me to look at
specifically, doctor?
Yeah, performance is like plenty good,
man, to have on the site.
I We're going to stop. We're gonna stop
spending like we're gonna stop doing
this thing where we spend two weeks
building an N and then like three months
agonizing over the details of the EN and
instead we're going to do two weeks
building the N try to find client fund
more science.
I can't get one mil.
Okay.
flying around the map.
It's funny.
Well, this thing doesn't build as is.
Oh.
Yeah. So, this is supposed to be of
zero.
Is it one agent or is it M or is it like
500 agents? What is it?
Wait, what?
You have one agent or 500?
Not Marl. Why is it
Why are there multiple agents in here?
RL agent is one.
But do you have 500 total? Like
Okay.
Okay, this thing is just like not
structured in a reasonable way here cuz
like
you're indexing based on tape size and
items, but like actions is supposed to
be a fixed space per agent.
And then like
in the C.
The only thing you're doing is setting
the action index zero to zero.
Tape size and max items are fixed. Okay,
but you're still setting you're setting
action index zero.
tape size plus
max items.
Used to have a script in here to
download weights to bin. Puffer export
Spencer. Puffer export terraform load
model path your model
500 items.
I don't know what this item is because
it's a touring machine. What's a what is
an item in the context of a touring
machine?
I also I don't understand why there are
four agents. Why it's a multi- aent
touring machine if they're not all AI
controlled.
Um, hey, uh, am I audible? Yeah. Hey.
Yeah. So actually uh it's only one
agent. Uh basically uh the problem is
solving EFX allocation. So there are
multiple agent which need to be
allocated items and they have utilities
like each agent has a utility for an
item. So the agent is not like multi
like real multi- agent R. It's just the
like the agent is only one. solving for
uh it's solving it's solving basically
which um agent gets which item so that
it's uh so that the allocation is NV3.
So then is the RL problem
is it like on the allocation or is it
like an action of an agent
like it's on the allocation. So the
problem actually solves for the
allocation. Okay. So then the agent is
not the thing the thing that it's being
assigned to is not the agent. The agent
is the uh the allocator.
Uh no actually we allocate we allocate
items to it. Yeah. Then what's the
action space? What how by what mechanism
do you interact with this thing?
So uh in in one like for like when we
take an action we set the we set the
memory the Turing tape and the result
and the halt halt flag.
But how how I don't like there are two
different problems here right like how
is it an allocation problem that's also
a touring machine problem like
I'm confused. Sure.
Okay. So, uh, basically what I'm trying
to learn an algorithm that allocates.
So,
you're trying to learn an algorithm that
allocates.
Yeah.
Something's got to happen with the
action space here because the action
space is like nuts. Um,
like here,
let's let's do it this way. So the
action space is the tape size plus the
max items plus one. What is the action
supposed to do? Like how is it supposed
to be interpreted?
So uh the action basically what it does
is uh at this moment it assigns um uh it
it assigns the memory. So whatever like
uh like if the action space is tape size
plus uh max items plus one the tape size
part of it just copies whatever it has
outputed to the memory tape. It just
updates the tape. I'm I'm planning to
change that but yeah for for now it
updates the tape this memory of the uh
this the whole tape at once.
Yeah. And the tape is size 1500 isn't
it?
Yeah. Okay. So, you've just created
you've just created an impossible
control problem. You've literally just
created something that's like several
orders of magnitude crazier than like uh
human like solving humanoid robotic zero
shot. Um can't have like a 1500
dimensional continuous action space like
that and expect it to learn anything.
The search space of that is ridiculous.
I mean, it's like
you're trying to guess a point in 1500
dimensional space and then you're
learning that with one bit feedback
which is the RL signal.
So like there are many things that you
can do here right like and that's not
even how like usually a touring machine
would work right like usually you have
individual actions that can be taken but
set a like setting an element of the
tape is reasonable for instance um
I think just structurally the end is a
bit confused and then as to why it's
slow
why is the tape even that big? Like,
I could get it. Uh, I could get it a
little less. I mean, it's I don't even
think it's like a matter to be fair. I
don't even think it's like a matter of
I don't think it's even a matter of
necessarily the tape being too big. It's
just in the way that you have the end
structured.
um
like you're trying to zero shot the
whole thing. Like is this still a
multi-step process if you're setting the
entire tape in one step?
Yeah. No, actually it's a multi-step
process. So, you know, it does it again.
Okay. So, here it's like quadratic or
something because that made it 100. It
must be quadratic because I it just I
reduced by a factor of 10 and it got
100x faster.
So you have what? However you're doing
this has got to be like quadratic in
tape size or agents or something. Um
because that's 9 million steps a second
immediately.
So definitely look at like just the
complexity of how this thing scales. And
then I I don't understand how it is that
you have a multi-step touring machine
process where it requires you to fully
set the memory of the tape at every
step.
Right. Actually, I actually thought
Yeah. Yeah. I I I thought about that. Uh
yeah, I'm just trying things out. Uh uh
I mean uh I can actually still justify
that whatever action it has taken in one
step, it's constant time. That's why I
did this like I thought that the other
thing where I set only a section a bit
to something else and then move the
pointer. Uh that would be I thought I
thought it would be more difficult to
learn or something.
The thing that you have here is
impossible to learn. Um
like algorithmically impossible. So,
uh, yeah, I would suggest if you're
if you model this thing off of how a
touring machine actually works, and it's
been a few years since I thought about
touring machines, but if you model this
off of how a touring machine actually
works, you should totally be able to RL
like move tape, read, write, like that
type of stuff, you can totally RL. Like
that could literally be like a
fivedimensional whatever. What is it
like? Move left, move right. It could be
like increment, decrement by some fixed
amount,
I guess. Read and store stuff like Yeah,
you literally end up with like a five or
six dimensional discrete action. And
then this thing will run. You can even
have the fullsize tape if you do that.
Uh, and then this thing should run
millions of steps per second and you
should be able to do stuff with it.
Yeah. Um, I'll do that. And then like
additionally,
the observation wouldn't be the entire
tape. I wouldn't think if you did that
either. You would make it local.
Like I don't know if I were going to
design a touring machine environment,
right? What I would do is I'd let it see
the tape like in some window around it.
So maybe it can see
maybe it can see like you know 16 places
to either side or something like that
and then it can just it can move it can
read it can write. Um, and then you can
actually you will actually have a chance
of establishing something with this
because it'll be really fast and it'll
have a small action space and like just
by random search essentially you should
eventually stumble onto interesting
things. And if you actually domain
randomize your problems, you could
literally learn like a touring machine
capable of solving a bunch of different
like very small like uh small
algorithmic problems. You just have to
like you just have to do it in a way
that makes sense for the RL because
otherwise you just hamstring yourself
instantly.
Yeah.
Uh I'll change that then. All right.
That would be my uh my advice. Go like
rethink about how you want to cast this
thing to uh a problem. Think about
having like small turning machine action
space local obs
scaling with size of tape and numbum
agents and stuff. And is numbum agents
supposed to be the number of heads? Is
it supposed to be a multi-head touring
machine or something?
No, no, it's it's it's just the part of
problem like it's
it's not related to the touring machine.
All right. Just what it's calling. Yeah.
Thanks, Joseph. Well, good good luck
with that. See, thanks.
All right.
He'll uh he'll manage that if he just
cleans it up a bit, formulates it better
for RL.
You can't just make an arbitrary sim and
then RL it is the thing. Like you
actually kind of have to you at least
have to design the sim with a RL in mind
if that makes sense.
Doesn't mean that you can't solve just
about whatever problem. It just means
you have to cast it in a way that makes
sense for the the RL, right?
Get another cup of coffee, figure out
how to load this dang dozer in, and then
get GPU drive and Terraform on the
website. That'll be a good plan. Be
back.
I had I had the original touring machine
in mind when making this. Then I had the
idea of turning machine generating a
matrix
multiply with the memory tape
O of N cubed my guy O of N cubed
classification
five to six actions exactly.
Also continuous action spaces suck and
we usually just discretize them anyways.
So,
honestly, this could be a very cool
environment if you execute it well. like
you could probably I I could see this
type of thing being something that
academics would be very very interested
in but you'd have to do it well enough
that you'd be able to like solve a bunch
of like uh simple like simple generated
problems automatically
the touring machine
that's all right stick around you'll
pick up more things like this.
You also got to make a visualizer for
this thing.
It's not that hard. You have a touring
machine. Look up any diagram of a
touring machine and make that
right.
Head is here. Tape goes this way. state
of tape different colors to represent
different values or just draw the value
in.
If you do this well, I'd be very excited
to see the results of this. But yeah,
it's one of those things where it's
really going to be down to the execution
of it. I think the idea actually does
make sense.
Just have to get it done correctly.
Have some clarity as well with how
you're building this.
I think that'd be my new favorite back
exercise as well.
It took a couple weeks of doing them,
but uh the single arm dumbbell rows just
feel really good now.
The sets of like 12
with like 70s are good.
Felt really bad doing it light for like
20, 30 reps. Felt really bad doing it
heavy for like six reps. This feels
good.
You want to hit milestones. That's the
idea with the stream and everything. So
yeah.
You'll be able to do it.
Yeah, no worries. Just keep the RL port.
Just keep it simple. You'll be able to
do it.
Go think of like the touring machine
examples in textbooks, you know, when
they're like teaching you touring
machines. you know, compute, you know,
solve this problem. Turning machine
solve this problem or whatever you do
that.
I took uh I took Sipster's course in uh
at MIT. It was the only mathy course I
took. Uh his like discrete math course.
It was decent in the sense like you know
it's not my normal thing but of course
sipser is sipser and uh unlike in
undergrad I actually had the 20 hours a
week that it took me to actually do the
material correctly. I did very well in
it. I actually felt like I understood
the process of the proofbased discrete
mathematics for once.
I mean, it's a pretty elementary course
if you actually do math, right? But
like, I could at least see how I could
kind of see how the process worked and I
could kind of see how, you know, the
people who come up with really amazing
stuff can come up with it and like the
sort of the mental toolkit you build up
over the course of being involved in an
area like an area like this of research.
Well, that was interesting enough, but I
don't know. Pure math is not really
my thing. I tend a lot to more towards
engineering,
hard sciences as well.
TI
welcome spy. Okay.
Property.
Okay. You want to upload archive? Cool.
I've not put anything on archive in a
while
July 11th. Is camera ready? Cool.
Easy.
Oh, it is there. I'm just dumb.
fuel
bulldozer.
Yeah.
I don't know about you. I think it's
slightly too big.
I don't know why it teleports around
like that.
Is it supposed to teleport around like
that? Oh, it's cuz I'm Well, first of
all, it's backwards.
So, uh,
it's going to look way cooler, though,
right?
Stuff matters, man. You got to make your
stuff look cool.
Got to make the stuff look cool.
viewport axi.
Okay. Now this is aligned
180.
Why does it jump around like this
though?
Oh, is it supposed to be human
controlled?
Looks like a good center point for it.
Right. Centered there. Yeah.
We have more of these, by the way. Like,
we have
I bought us uh this full set.
These look pretty cool, right? And
especially you see the digger
right there. We got digger, we got dump
truck,
we got steamroller, we got big
steamroller.
Actually, following our discussion on
dirt economics, um
I realized my family is going to need a
ton of dirt uh in construction soon. So,
I just said, "Hey, why don't you guys
just dig a pool instead of paying for
all the dirt?"
Just dig a pool.
Probably be the same price as not
digging a pool and paying for the dirt.
Free pool.
All right. Where we get this is human
control.
We don't have official Windows support.
Jason,
if it doesn't work with CUDA on Windows,
it's because CUDA on Windows is weird.
Little high for 10 cubic yard. Still
dirt expensive. Yeah.
I mean, they were thinking like they
wanted to like elevate a piece of
construction so they have to like make a
hill. Like jeez. May as well just dig a
moat around it to get the dirt.
I would not be complaining because a a
circular like lap pool would be pretty
awesome.
[Music]
This guy
Mark to skip.
The keys are reversed. So I assume
that's not intended.
Oh, it's stuck as well. It doesn't let
me uh
model prop backwards
once facing what looks to be the correct
direction.
I can do it this way though it this
seems wrong.
Oh, there's no rotating here. It's
weird.
Move. So fast.
Holy.
I think I like I set the FPS pretty low
as well.
We might have to do uh
So, one of the things I did you see how
I did interpolation on Breakout and Pong
lately? I added this interpolation thing
where
I guess it's a little different for you.
I did it on uh
Rareware would be the good example,
but I keep the frame rate high and I
interpolate the movements.
Now, see, you can't set it to 20. That
looks fy
Good father's day. Yes indeed.
Let's puff her some lips.
Puff the lips.
Yeah, it also it gets stuck on the
border
like you and you end up having to like
steer out of it. It's really awkward.
Well, like
here.
So, can I even get out of this?
I can get out of this one. Sometimes you
can't reverse though.
Like if I do this,
can I reverse? See? Oh, no. I can
reverse. That's weird. I couldn't
reverse before.
should probably give humans the slower
of the two.
The objective of this end is to
terraform everything. Oh yeah, there you
go. Look at that. That's so much better,
man.
That's like way more doable.
Hold control. Yo, that's awesome.
Look at that.
That's pretty close to the model.
It's not centered.
Let me see if that's a model problem,
though. No, it's centered in here.
That's awesome.
This should be this the screenshot
actually
Why didn't you tell me about this, man?
And this goes straight to the website.
It's par for the course in my end of
work amigo
for the last two m it is right. You
don't have it in tower climb or any of
the other ones.
It's kind of cool you independently came
up with that though cuz I had similar
viz stuff I would do in uh in my PhD.
GPU drive? Looks cooler. Yeah, we're
going to get that in next. So,
uh, Terraform did not refresh.
I go to console
Okay, this thing is caching for some
dumb reason.
And I also I made the shader, so I don't
know what it's doing.
Oh, did I not?
Maybe I did it wrong. Hang on.
Yeah, you can definitely get stuck
still, man.
I don't think I have a print screen.
It's just 75% board.
Yeah, this is going to be [ __ ] quality
though if I do a screen shot of this
here. We'll do
Okay. So, those are still the wrong
dozers.
takes a while to compile.
Kind of weird.
Oh,
well
dozer's here.
Let's see what shader it is that's
breaking. Okay.
fragment shader. Yeah. Okay, there it
is. So, it's in the fragment shader.
If you have a Robocode doing stuff, I
can merge things today. Be fun
for wedding flying back in today. All
right.
busy. Then
we're getting all the new M's under the
uh
under the website. You can see Well,
that one's not done, but you can see all
the new M's here.
Haven't done the full code review yet
cuz you said it didn't um we didn't have
any like nets training or anything on
it, right? How's GPU situation? I have
the GPUs working and stable. It's going
to take me some hours at some point to
put all the cases back on, but check
this out.
This is
uh super linear
state-of-the-art on neural MMO the with
400 billion
observations trained.
I don't think a run of this scale has
ever been done on this little hardware.
couldn't get the docker
working. Yeah, let me know on that. I
can I can help you figure that out. That
is something that you should know for
just your PhD in general. It will be
very useful. Though UV has gotten like
kind of fast to where you can just set
up with UV now, but there's still some
things where Docker is just nice to have
There we go.
Rock was dumb. That's the usual culprit.
Also, this is a really good aspect. Like
this 720p for the M's has been really
good.
Yeah, you can definitely still get
stuck. I got to tell Spencer about that.
Ah, this be
press
fuel though
and
Spencer, did he send me a map?
A map.
Okay.
Send me a map for GPU drive.
And after that, I think we'll just um
start looking for well, we'll have to
start collecting all of the videos.
Yeah, they just freaking broke the
badge.
this thing not just have one.
Discord should just have a
have a car for this. Sure. I'm sure as
well.
isometric cars.
These are 2D
What are these? The We got spheres
rendered around all the cars.
I wish I could just get us like a better
freaking car asset.
Surely there's got to be some like cool
cars, right?
Oh, these drones actually they have some
good drone models.
I'll get this on the website and I'll
leave it up to you if you want to tweak
assets or visuals or anything.
I don't know. I think we
I kind of like the Tron vibe for some of
this stuff.
Where's the like the show lines button,
man?
Shift.
Cool.
Shift like hides everything else.
We not make it hide everything else like
this.
Hang on. This We need to get like a good
freaking screenshot for this thing, man.
Like it's it's like 99% of the way
there, but it looks like a third as good
as it should.
Yeah, but like it it's going to look
really freaking cool if you can see the
full road with the overlay like that.
Where's the thing that disables drawing
if you have was it shift?
So, we just do this like you don't need
to remove the geometry.
You can still tell because of the lines
what it's seeing.
that was the goals,
Hang on.
We'll remove the goals, right?
What the [ __ ] keeps happening to this
thing?
Yeah. No, it's like cuz it collides
instantly or something.
I thought you could switch cars with the
arrows. Like I thought you could switch
cars though.
But I'm still not driving it. It's
driving itself and it's crashing into
[ __ ] right? Also
Okay. What is just chill out and don't
do anything as an action?
right, I will let you sort that. Let me
just fix this at least so I can get
something.
I figure out where it actually like
stops at drawing [ __ ]
Oh, what are those arrows?
What are those arrows?
The arrows at the end of the lines are
like going nuts. They're
like they're like phantom cars that are
just spinning there. Yeah.
Like there are no cars there, but they
just show us they're spinning.
This should be like four
seven, right? So it's like four.
This is like
seven.
finding for vizdoom been done before.
Would it be any faster than sample
factory? Uh, we technically do.
If you check, there's an old one and it
will give you some warnings on like
files you have to move around. I briefly
did a thing with Vizdoom where I found
out that there was an unused render
setting uh that lets you render at lower
resolution natively than most people had
tried. And if you do that, I think I got
it to like 100k steps per second. So,
you probably could do something with
that if you're interested. And it would
be a very cool environment. It would
still be like an order of magnitude
slower than even our more complex puffer
atoms. Uh, for sure, unless you found a
way to get it to like not render or like
Yeah, there'd be some hacking basically
with it. There would definitely be some
hacking. It could be very cool, but
there would definitely be some hacking.
I will say your Tetris ends looks
awesome. Like that's now one of my
favorite uh my favorite of the ends.
Like just look at this thing. Oh, it
does flip by the way. It just it flips
very fast. I watched it for a bit. Hang
on.
Look how awesome your end looks.
This is how it's going to show up on the
website.
drone is ready to go. PR is live.
Give me five minutes, Sam, and I will go
through the whole thing with you. I just
want to finish this last thing that I
was doing here.
Should be
Sample factory reports a 300K raw. Was
that on a 64 core GPU? Uh 64 core CPU.
What was that on?
All right. And then did I make
I think I already made this thing.
raw sim
300k
PO
100. There's no way that they get PO at
140K with a non-trivial policy. Like
just based on the numbers,
unless they're doing some weird thing,
it's still no.
Like maybe if they have it down sampled
to like 64 by 64 or something and then
maybe
we're kind of at the point where most of
our stuff is now like faster than sample
factory was. So like
I like yeah you can probably beat Sample
Factory with our infra. Um but it's just
our stuff is all designed to be an order
of magnitude faster than Sample Factory.
It's just we haven't used any of the
ends that they've tried to speed up
because they just bottleneck so hard on
the pure sim.
I mean like if you get trainings
training in the hundreds of thousands at
least then we can do something but like
even then so for like multiGPU training
for instance right you immediately run
out of cores because if you're
bottlenecked by the sim even on 32 cores
then you go to 32 core 6GPU machine and
you're still screwed right you can't do
anything with the extra GPUs
that's the real issue
like we have this result right here.
This is 400 billion steps into training.
This is neural MMO 3. This is a uh soda
result. And this is like probably
something like this has not been seen
since 2019 era. Open AI. And this type
of stuff is just enabled by having fast
sim. And it's like fast sim on the scale
of there is literally no info you can
write to make that thing faster unless
you specifically go into the Doom code
and like
I don't know you'd have to extract state
based obs from the Doom code. If you
could get that then you can probably do
it. If you could make Doom return like
state-based obs, you could probably do
Okay. Um, the only thing I wanted to do
before I forget and then look at drone
is
wa
these. Yeah, these controls are
backwards and non-ontinuous.
Let me do uh let's go look at the drone
stuff. All right, Finn. What you got for
me?
9:06.
Perfect timing for 3 0 as well.
I stole a little bit of your quitterian
math as well
because we have um I mean this is like
way worse physics but we have this thing
and you can see I mean there's no policy
on this but you can see all the planes
and stuff spilling out of here.
Ideally we're going to get some real
physics on this at some point.
Let's see. Drone M.
You're here, right, Finn? Because we can
do we can uh go through this right now
live.
All right. Awesome.
Yeah, there's so many M's. I've like to
give you an idea of the last few days,
look at all the M's I've gotten onto the
the site that had to be built. So, this
was this is 20. All right. This is 20.
And then
this is 3 0 all the M's.
All right, let's take a quick look. I
can hop into the Discord as well in case
questions if you want. We'll see. But I
will start looking at this code either
way. Both join. Awesome.
This is some good work. I will say that
um the that new like battle simulation,
it only took me like four days. A day
and a half of that was like banging my
head against the basic physics of it.
The physics is such a pain.
See what we have here. We've got drone.
We've got some likely swept
hyperparameters, it looks like. Hello.
Welcome. Congrats on being done with
exams. I do not envy you one bit on
those. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, thanks.
Yeah, those those kind of just suck.
All right, we've got
presumably this is initial orientation
and angular momentum and everything.
You have full state. Uh,
we can't see what you're looking at in
real time, but I will share it on
Discord and then there will be no
latency.
Sounds good.
Another perk of this
mute stream otherwise you know. Yeah.
All right. There we go. Just
Okay. Um
so you have full initial state it looks
like as part of the end. Yeah.
Uh yes this is position velocity
uh orientation and angular momentum.
Yeah. Angular velocity but yeah angular
velocity.
My last physics course was 12 13 years
ago. I don't know. I'm brush I'm
brushing up on stuff. I'm starting to do
a lot more. I don't know. I've been like
going back through really old courses
trying to like because we're trying to
think how like what we can apply this
stuff to now that we have all this
cracked out RL. Um and drones is
actually a very good opportunity. So
there's probably some stuff around
puffer do with drones. Yeah. Yeah. We'd
like to make it multi- aent at some
point. Maybe like a like a tag
environment or something like that. I
mean I right now in this thing
I mean I don't have uh I gotta like
actually make this thing
I call it school.
That thing will train for a bit. Um and
I'll show you once this thing is it
looks really cool but the physics suck
in it so far but we're thinking of doing
things like that.
So it should be a lot of fun. Can you
see Can I see what? Sorry. Can you see
the stream thing? Oh it's Yeah.
Oh, okay. It's just me then. Never mind.
Based on your mic, I think it's probably
connection.
Oh, really? Is it not good? It's like
dropping some packets or whatever. I
think
All right. Okay. Oh, it's fine with me.
Maybe it's a trans.
Huh.
Okay. That's weird.
I wouldn't think I would be having any
streams at five yet. Streams at 6K.
Well, regardless, let me know if
anything that you miss here. Um,
is it system load?
All right. Whatever.
I think it was actually not your mic. I
think it's that it's my system's running
at full because I launched this train
job.
All right. Okay. All right. That'll
that'll be done in a minute anyways. But
um okay, so
we've got random actions in the sea.
Got the new style allocations. This is
like very very new style allocations.
That's nice.
Saves me time from refactoring.
I never even do these checks because
like if you if you can't malic stuff,
you're kind of screwed anyways, but
sure.
Yeah, we haven't looked at this file in
a while, so should be fine. Should be
fine. So yeah, like this is I never
really do this in the C because it's
like yes, technically if you want the
program to have a 100% chance of running
without errors, you do this. But it adds
like a ton of lines and it's literally
like the only time this fails is if your
system's out of memory,
right?
Hello. Hello.
Let's see. So,
this is going to be the big file. We'll
take a look at the other one first. I
did steal some of this plot map. And
then I realized Rayb has uh you know,
Ray actually has a lot of the plot math
built in.
Right. Okay. Right. Yeah, we were
getting some like naming collisions, I
think. But yeah, we sort of went with
our own stuff.
I tried I went with my own stuff first.
I think it is equivalent to be fair, but
it is nice. is the one the the ray stuff
is the same and also it doesn't depend
on having the rendering up like you
don't actually have to initi it's just
kind of the same thing as a standalone.
Oh, this this ran by the way. So here
you can get a sense of the multi- aent.
Uh this is not even a particularly good
model, but
uh just to give you like a little idea
of what we can do with our RL now.
All right,
thousand agent. That's a lot bigger than
it was a couple weeks ago or maybe a
week ago. I think I there camera
thousand agent battle environment.
We'll actually see if they get too
close. The lasers going off. Yeah,
there.
Zap. Very cool. Zap. Zap.
So, yeah, this thing has uh the drone
dynamics suck in this because I didn't
port the full things over. But uh this
is like air to air, air to ground,
ground to air, ground to ground,
separate units, like six different types
of separate units. Um yeah, so this is
the type of stuff we can do with with a
little bit of control in buffer now. So
I'm pretty excited about this drone
stuff. Very nice. Plus, did you just see
the uh the order that was signed a
couple days ago make uh America make it
a lot easier to do drone stuff in
America?
No. No. Apparently, yeah, this is like
literally the the drone boom is about to
start because of that. Yeah. Well,
that's good timing. Yeah, it's very good
timing. There will be stuff in here.
All right.
Massive in it. All these args. Cool.
You set the initial date like uh
We're doing reset. Yeah. Is there a
reason though that you have the full
initial state specified from Python?
Um I think that was just the way it was
done in um one of the other examples.
Oh, okay. Yeah. So, you only need to
specify like stuff that you want to be
able to change in the config, right? So,
like if you wanted to be able to specify
the full state from config, then you
would do this, right? Okay. It's not
going to hurt anything. C as well.
What's that? Could we remove it from
binding C then as well or is that Yes.
Yes, you could. You just have to you
have to init it somewhere. So if it gets
calicked and you want it set to zero,
you're good. Otherwise, it goes in,
right? Um
this is the single agent invocation.
There's actually like a single like a
oneliner that you can even do for this
um for a single agent, but when you're
going to multi- aent, it'll look like
this anyways.
Fine.
This is like a correct basic binding.
It's fine. Like this. And then we'll
look at the main meat of this
policy real quick. All
it's just the default policy pretty
much. Oh yeah. You don't if you just
have the default policy, you don't even
have to mess with it. can just like
policy like just set policy equal
policy. Well, I think I think we were
messing with it originally and it kind
of and it just ended up being the same.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, I'll see I will look and see if I
have anything that's iffy with that. Uh
oh, the one thing I wanted to check is
the action base.
Okay, so you do have it being
continuous. One of the things I've been
thinking about and one of the things
that might make training easier. Uh we
haven't done full experiments on this,
but so far it seems like discrete has
just been way easier to optimize than
continuous. So one of the easiest things
we could do here is like change this
from box of four to like a multi-iscreet
of 999 and nine and then you just
discretize the four motor like four or
motor motor intensities to like nine
values. And then possibly it could be a
lot easier to learn. Possibly not. Um
but yeah, that's after that's like
definitely worth doing. And then if you
do that, you have to remember to change
the types becomes int. So the action has
to become int. But yeah, that's it.
Right. Let's go to the main me of this.
It's not that bad. 540 lines. A lot of
it's quturnian math as well. Yeah. Yeah.
Will be. Well, I think only only a
couple hundred is drone. The rest of it
just like rail stuff.
Cool. So, we've got Yeah, this is the
exact type of thing that I was like
looking at having to do for uh my new
sim and then I went, "Ah, that looks
like hard physics."
Yeah, this this took a bit of
experimentation. Sure. Well, you're
doing it at a good time when you're
actually like you've recently done some
stuff at least in undergrad. Yeah.
It's like there are a lot of these
things that I could have done eight
years ago that it's just like I have not
done that in forever.
Yeah,
you got your basic math. Yeah, I
remember reading all this stuff a lot.
I had a fun time reading a bunch about
quitterians uh building the schooling,
so I'm perfectly up to date on all this
crap.
and time of So that will um this this
right here is probably a bad idea.
And the reason for that is this gives
you time in seconds
and
so this is going to call a netit. Uh
this is going to get called on each
environment, right?
Yeah. Huffers really fast. Those are all
going to end to the same thing
because you call s rand every time. So I
recently added I think it gets done for
you. I have not rigorously tested this
but
so here we look at what's this env
sand
will seed
uh to this seed value here
and then
yeah you just pass you know you pass a
seed argument to this so it'll s rand
it'll set it to a different seed every
time. All right. Okay. But like you can
pass the seed from yourpi. I think you
have this in here, right? When you init
with the pie,
I basically I took care of it for you
for this exact reason. Um seed right
here. So this seed just like increment
by one every time instead of just
passing a static thing. Yeah. And then
you should be good,
right? So that's one thing to definitely
because that can really mess with stuff.
Do you do like obstacle generation or
something?
Not yet. No, we had that in the original
Python environment. Um, but it it makes
the maths a lot more complicated for
like collision.
Yeah.
You can't just treat the drone as a
sphere and like
no radius. Um
well we then you have to you have to
treat the colliders as spheres as well
right? Oh yeah you have to do sphere box
collision I guess right? Yeah yeah
that's slightly annoying.
Yeah it's slightly annoying.
We originally did it with like vector
projections and stuff so it's not it's
not crazy but it is probably another
hundred lines or something. Yeah. Now,
there will definitely be opportunity for
stuff. We're trying to figure out what
to do in the in the drone space because
there's like the racing stuff. There's
like defense stuff. There's there tons
of different areas and we're kind of
trying to figure out what we want to do.
We're looking for more industry stuff
cuz the wall of servers behind me does
not pay for itself.
All right. All right. What's the uh
what's the cost per box at the minute?
I mean, the individual desktops when I
first started getting them, they were
like 4K and then they went up to like
5.5, I think, for one of the more recent
ones I bought. If I want to buy more,
they're quoting me at like 7K now, which
is ridiculous because of the Yeah. And
then the tiny boxes are 25k each. So,
those are fun. Yeah.
So, yeah. Like 100,000 bucks worth of
hardware.
But it is very fast.
And uh if I were to rent if I were to
rent like an 8 8x 800, it's not even
really that much faster than a tiny box
like at all. Um yeah, that would be 100
bucks per day,
right? Okay. Oh, no, I'm sorry. 100
bucks per day. 200 bucks per day from
the best provider. Second best provider,
400 bucks a day.
Like the hardware prices are just like
they just make up numbers. It's crazy.
Yeah.
rotor offsets. Oh, do you draw the
rotors?
Yeah, we just draw little spheres sort
of positioned in across around the the
central sphere.
There's a video on the Oh, you just you
made the Okay. Well, I'm going to run
this afterwards. Uh, sure. Maybe I
should
I got a quadcopter model. I can like
Oh, okay. You just I see what you did.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, we can totally get you a
quadcopter. Yeah, this thing behaves
like way more realistically than my my
drones do.
So, that is solid. Yeah, that that took
a while.
That's definitely solid.
And I think that like right after we
release, pretty much right after we
release, I'm going to be doing a lot of
like drone stuff personally, a lot of my
time. Welcome, Ara.
The the first iteration of the physics
was a bit a bit crazy. Um was just doing
like barrel rolls and stuff and like
just flying upside down, but
managed to fix it since then.
Yeah. Yeah. It's uh
well also we'll get you the the nice
quadcopter model board and stuff as
well. Mhm.
Then I think just generally this whole
like kind of like a four-point thrust
model, didn't you? Yeah. Yeah. So that
type of stuff in general, if we could
like if we can just figure out because I
don't want to go to like a full physics
engine, they're so heavy and so
annoying. But like if we can just figure
out like a basic like point mass thrust
model. Um like that would be that would
unlock a lot of control stuff for us,
you know? Like that's kind of already
enough to get like a bunch of different
vehicle types and form factors behaving
like better than most basic game
physics.
Yeah.
Wait, what? That's it? Where' the Where'
the logic go?
Which which logic?
The actual
Oh, I totally just skipped over the
actual Yeah, it's just really quite
short. It's not I skipped over a lot of
stuff somehow. Okay, here's your quat
math.
This I looked at
What may be normalized? No. Is it unit?
It gets normalized later. Yeah, it's but
in the ops.
Well, I don't know what the max I don't
know what the max values are. If they go
up to like just pi or if it gets more
Yeah. And after after every C step we
normalize it. Good then. Yeah. Then this
is well done. This is like what you
want. Perfect.
Nice. and
what are your thoughts on clamping the
actions between negative one and one at
this at the top there?
Is that is that just fine? Uh yeah, you
can do it. You're just you're going to
deal with continuous jank for now. Uh
this is that was my one big suggestion
was to discretise. So discretise and RNG
are the two big things so far. Um that
actually could make a big difference. Uh
because like continuous what we've seen
there's a whole bunch have you seen like
unstable training with Nans?
Uh no. Okay. Well then maybe you're just
good. But in a lot of continuous things
we see like just stuff gets out of
whack. Um
and we don't know if it's fundamental or
if like there's a way around it. But
like so far our best results on M's have
been with with discrete also right pet
peeve don't use tabs and this is not
just a me thing like everyone will tell
you don't use tabs I thought you said
last last time you like tabs I I changed
it to tabs just for you wait what okay
who the [ __ ] tells you
no no no no no it was spaced it was cuz
you had it too spaced I said use four
spaced so when I I think I said use four
spaced tabs, which means use tabs that
like when you tab it expands to four
spaces.
Yeah, that that's that's fine. I can I
can fix that. No, no, no, no, no. I
didn't. There's this funny result that
everyone sites whenever you post code
with tabs, which is there's like there's
this funny statistic that programmers uh
who use tabs make less.
Okay, don't use tabs. But no, the real
reason that you don't use tabs is
because they're really easy to screw up
and mix with spaces, which is really
annoying. Yeah.
Right. So, everyone just sets tab
expand.
Yeah. It was all um It was all spaces
before. I just It was two space though,
wasn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, that
was the thing. I I don't know why it did
that, but
I can sort that out. Yeah. Just change
that. It's easy. All right. And now body
frame. I will merge this though before I
make you do that because this is we
should get this Epic.
I've been so tempted to like buy some
quadcopter parts and start like
soldering stuff.
How much are they nowadays? Less than
servers.
Okay, fine.
But I do remember that they sometimes
are quite difficult. Uh I had I remember
I had a high school buddy who ordered
like a really nice one. It's part of
like the robotic stuff he was doing and
it was like impossibly small to like
solder stuff.
Like nobody could actually solder it.
We've managed to stay well clear of that
so far.
We have to get this running on a real
quadcopter, right? See if it works. We
have We have tried um but not with a
very good quadcopter, so it didn't go
very well. I actually think I know how
to help you with that. Um do you know
how do you know how domain randomization
works?
It was just the the drone we had was so
bad you just couldn't read data from it
fast enough to Ah, okay. That'll be an
issue. But if it's the physics, you know
how domain randomization works. Is this
like randomizing the parameters of the
the end? Yeah. Including the physics,
you jitter the laws of physics a little
bit. Like you can jitter acceleration
and jitter like what happens. And the
idea is you end up having to learn a
ridiculously robust policy, but whatever
the heck the conditions are in the real
world, you're just good. Now, this is
not this doesn't work like on its own
perfectly for stuff like humanoids, but
for quadcopters with like it's zero
degrees of freedom for Yeah, you're
totally good. Mhm. So,
I'm just about to push up the fixed uh
indentation. If you hold on a sec, uh
integrate quturnian.
What? Hang on. I don't know if that's
the correct terminology, but let me let
me actually make sure. All right. So,
thus
force
ve 3 f body.
Why is this
why is this applied in the plus z or is
this plus z in the local coordinate
system?
Uh that is that'll be Z in the drone
like the drone coordinates. Okay. Which
we've defined as up. Gotcha. So it's in
local coordinates and that's correct.
Arm length times
force difference.
Okay. Okay.
I see how that works.
angular damping
yeah, this is like this is really nice.
This is the exact type of thing I was
trying to figure out how to do. Um, this
is just really well done.
Cheers. Thank you.
If we could figure out how to make like
um
like an easy way to just apply this
level of physics sim like a couple
different form factors, we we could do a
lot of stuff with this. Heck, even just
the drone like the one quadcopter drone
form factor is already pretty dang good.
Yeah, I can very easily show you how to
like apply randomization and stuff to
this as well.
Nice.
Yeah, we've got plenty of time this
summer. Well, enough time. Awesome. Good
to go. That's awesome. Yeah, this is
perfect timing as well because we're
very much like we are looking to do
stuff in drone space. Um we're still
trying to figure out who we're going to
like pitch stuff to, but uh yeah,
they're like we could definitely figure
something out with this.
I've just pushed another commit which
fixes all the indentation.
Thank you. So
from definition dot
Yeah, you just times by half for some
reason just
probably the thing.
So this is
that you is this acceleration is it
uh accelerations usually get
one half no v gets an acceler
velocity gets acceleration because
second integral whatever.
Okay, I see what you mean by
integrations. This is just a um
yeah, that that could maybe be improved,
but it it's fine. Does does the job. Um
this type of stuff usually gets to be
unstable, I think, in long sims, but RL
is self-correcting, so like maybe this
just works. Yeah. We found with even
like massive DT, it was just fine. It
just kind of did its thing. Yeah. Yeah.
Because I RL is just selfcorrecting
like Yeah. The question will be the sim
to real gap, right? Yeah. You sure? I
don't know.
remember to stop
did
elicit oiler can be unstable.
Yeah, I am aware of uh I'm aware of
that. I don't know if you need RK4 for
something like this though because like
your goal is not to have a system and
then just run it for many steps and have
it match the real outcome. Um,
you have a self-correcting control
system, but I don't know if you need
something like RK4
like you I mean, it wouldn't be a big
change anyway. So,
before I just don't want to have to look
at the math.
Yeah, fair enough. We can we can do
that. Uh, it's it's one of those things
where like I know I'm going to have to
go back at some point and like just
relearn all the math, but it's like my
brain has just gone so far in the
direction of building [ __ ] It's like a
very different skill. It's a very
different skill set. Like what do I
think of all day is like how do I take
incredibly complicated system and make
it as simple as fast as possible. That's
basically all I think about all day
which is very different from
the formalism.
When do you think 3.0 will release then?
Is it sort of couple days? It's got to
just be done. Like we're It's just been
so much work. I think at this point
we're getting all the things on the
site. I'm going to today attempt to find
somebody to cut me together a trailer. I
like I don't know where. I'm going to
see maybe Upwork. I got to find somebody
who does like trailer like intros for
YouTubers or whatever. I want somebody
who will like work with me just to find
some cool way to present this stuff.
Like I give them all the clips of the
environments. They'll find like some way
to cut together like a 30 second trailer
thing for this and hopefully we get a
lot of eyes on this cuz like basically
at this point I've worked on this for
over a year. Um pretty much double time.
Um
yeah, it's this last few weeks in
particular.
Uh, yeah, we're in a decent enough
position where I can like maintain
servers and such, but I want to be able
to grow this to where I can be like
actually bringing more people on uh and
having, you know, this be like a proper
private research lab where we're really
really accelerating the field. Um, so
for that it's like I got to find ways to
like get more eyes on and find some
bigger contracts for us. That's kind of
the next thing. And hey, drone space is
definitely one of those.
Yeah, that sounds super cool. I can't
lie. Well, I think I think we're in if
if you want any help with anything.
Absolutely. I got to figure out in what
capacity, but like I was I already as
soon as I saw like the quality of this
code, I was like, "All right, I got to
figure out what capacity." But yeah, we
should do something for this. Yep. Cool.
like it's kind of on me to like first
actually get a formal contract before I
hire people or like pay people for a
specific project. So, I got to figure
that part out. But then yeah, we can uh
do something with this. Cool.
render. Actually, I do want to see on
the rendering how you did
Yeah, cuz there's this annoying thing
where you have to like redo you have to
like redo the calcs, right? In order to
figure out how to how to render it in
world space, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I had to deal with
this as well.
The Rail code is probably the bit we're
most unsure on because it it's not the
first C code we've ever written
obviously, but it is the first RALIB
we've ever written. So, it's a bit
trickier. So, with this thing, I think I
might have actually found something that
can help you.
Mhm. How you're doing the rod. You have
rotor offsets.
And where do you get the orientation?
Hang on.
Sphere.
And where do you get the
So, the way that I did this, I'll show
you
this. This also took me a while. Like, I
know that this stuff is annoying.
Yeah.
You want to see a a big end? Well,
admittedly, this is way larger than it
needs to be.
I did this like a couple weeks ago. Um,
it has all these different units
and got the clock math in it.
The way that I did this for again this
math with the ray one
all I did is I got I did a quaternian to
matrix
on the orientation which is the plot of
the the model and I just set the
transform.
Yeah. So this ended up being super easy.
Everything else I tried would just like
screw it up. And like it looks like you
did get the math there eventually, but
something like this might be easier. Um,
actually I wasn't I'm going to be
honest, I wasn't 100% sure about using
the array math functions because one
they're kind of verbose, but also like
you know if one of them is slow for
whatever reason then it's like I'm going
to have to go rewrite a bunch of crap.
Um, and I don't know I think I looked
and I think that they use float 32
default not 64. It's like it's
reasonable but I don't know if there's
anything in there that like needs to be
improved. So, I'm not 100% on just using
the ray botmath. I would be equally
happy uh just making our own like
standalone quitterians.h or whatever. Uh
if that's the way we want to go like
basically just take yours and add a
couple extra functions and we could just
be good there. The only thing is we
would have to output we'd have to have
like something to output this ray
transform. I think that's like the
easiest way to draw it. It shouldn't be
that hard. It's just
like this is just like a super basic
data structure if you check the source
for it, right? And then
yeah, let's go. Let's go run this and
see what we what we can do here.
Super solid N. This is like I don't
think anybody has submitted me uh N code
this clean on their first like their
first PR. This is quite This is very
good. I mean, even like if you've seen
the some of the stuff that Spencer is
doing now, like he's building awesome
awesome stuff. Go look at the triple
triad code if you want to see like the
Delta. So, it's like it's very
impressive to be doing this on your
first first PR especially like I don't
think I ever see this type of stuff from
undergrads like ever. So, well done.
Very well done. Thank you. Cheers.
We we really enjoy this stuff. Pretty
much every every waking hour that isn't
uni work is spent on reinforcement
learning. Hey, I'm trying to make all
this stuff easier. I will here. You know
what? Let me let me just give you a
sneak peek of like I got something
that's pretty darn cool. Um now I think
actually the model's gotten better since
I pulled it and I have to reduce the
frame rate, but
This is something that took me
eight years.
I'm still slightly behind because I'm on
the stream. Discord's not not having it.
But
yeah, I think I think we both found you
through your um your thesis defense on
YouTube. Yeah. So, this thing here, this
model is trained on approximately 4,000
years worth of gameplay.
It is better. Okay. It is better at the
game than I am.
Um, it is like
it actually knows how to use and like
equip and buy and sell to some extent
equipment.
Um, it knows how to like pick its fights
because there's enemies that are too
strong for it and enemies that are not.
Um,
yeah, this is like dramatically better
than anything I did during my PhD. And
this thing trains in like 200 billion
was two days on the tiny box. Not even.
Wow. Yeah.
So about 2.2 million steps per second
training on the six. Wow. Okay.
And uh the impressive thing about that
is that it uses the local CPU. So it the
CPUs it's designed to be fast enough
that it can actually serve that amount
of data um just using the local coursees
which is the key thing because neural
MMO 2 during my PhD ran like maybe a
thousand steps a second per core. This
thing runs a million plus.
Well, I think even when we we first
wrote drone and puffer like back the
original iteration, I think we went from
about 2,000 to a million steps per
second or something like that was
ridiculous. And I've sort of I've worked
on making it easier and easier. And then
like this environment when I made this,
this was one of the first things I did
after graduating. It just didn't it just
didn't train well at all. And then kind
of just like over the course of making
the algorithm better and better and all
the improvements we've made, this is
just like a slightly bit bigger model
now trained for longer and it just does
this. Um yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Is super cool. It's not like
totally genius yet. Like it for
instance, I think it has a better bow in
its inventory right now and it doesn't
realize it. Um, but it's also like I
suspect that the observations could be
structured way better than they are
right now. So,
like yeah, this thing is very quickly
going to be
like this environment I think as is is
at least as complex as some of the stuff
that was being done Open AI and Deep
Mind in 2019. like not not Alpha Star or
Dota, not that complex, but like capture
the flag or um yeah, hide-and-seek,
absolutely that complex. And we're
training it for like comparable or more
data than those projects trained on, but
we're doing it on like six GPUs instead
of a thousand. Yeah. Yeah, that's
slightly insane.
Yeah, this is where RL is going.
How much more performance do you think
you can squeeze out of,
you know, this current stuff?
Mhm. Probably quite a bit if I tried.
Probably quite a bit.
We still have there's so many more
things I can do. But I think that the
next thing is going to be like to try to
make this work on a few real problems
first just so that like I mean like we
have the training like this type of
training is just not a thing that
happens anywhere else in the So we
should be able to basically infinitely
fund all this research and once that's
settled we can kind of just like
optimize the crap out of everything.
Mhm. That's the plan. Very nice.
All right. So,
Okay.
I just steer it or not really.
All right. Cool. And we do.
You guys do AI stuff outside of RL
first?
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, a little bit. A little bit.
It's not an easy sub it's not an easy
sub field to jump into. Like I did NLP
stuff. I did language modeling before
transformers like before transformers
were a thing. And then I did uh what
else did I do? I did some like weird
like dynamically assembled vision
architecture stuff and the neural MMO
was kind of just the big thing.
Well, this this summer we're we're
trying to kind of learn the ropes of
research. We've got um at the university
like a position to do some language
model reinforcement learning stuff which
should be cool. The LMRL stuff is tough
because like you don't get a million
step per second training. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. like all the things they're like
all these things that language model
people are like slowly discovering and
they're like discovering them like
slower than we are with our tiny amount
of resources just because like we run a
million times faster than the language
models.
We're we're hoping and praying though
that once we start next week we'll get
access to the apartments H100s that
we're currently locked out from
some super computer. Yeah. Yeah.
This thing actually trains for quite a
while, huh? It It maxes out at five 5.0.
Why is it set to train for so long? I I
just It's just a big number. I don't
know. Yeah, we didn't use that for
sweep. But
you may you may find you you want to
sweep again because we were running it
on the like student GPUs which aren't
great and can't last very long because
other people are trying to use it as
well.
There no any file for this?
Uh there should be
yet one.
Oh, there should be. It was training
remarkably well for not having a Ah,
it's in the wrong. Got to go into ocean.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Oh, did I put it in the
wrong place? Sorry.
You do uh anything that gets like
submitted as a native puff run the
ocean.
It was in the right place before. It was
just um we were many commits behind on
my my local copy. So, had to do a bit of
messing around with git.
Yep. I clearly messed it up somewhere
along the way.
num m got drone.
We have what total
1 billion total times.
Okay. Not 1 million either. Can't read.
Yeah.
Update. Oh, this is no RNN as well.
That's funny.
What do you think it would benefit from
it?
I I find it pretty amusing that you're
doing this with a 2,800 parameter model.
Yeah.
What? Wait, what? What?
All right. To give you guys an idea here
of how ridiculous that is,
you see that 800k steps per second?
That's on a CPU.
Yep. Right. Okay.
So, that network is so small that even
if I put my 4090 on it, it's not that
much faster than the CPU.
Mhm. Let me try something here because
that's silly. That is just silly.
Actually, here we'll get a baseline
first. We'll see if I can improve your
drone model at all because it doesn't
look like it's perfect yet.
No, it definitely definitely isn't.
Well, you have two. All right, I'm going
to teach you something here. So,
you know how
did anybody ever tell you about like
local minima in a deep learning?
Yeah. Okay. Now, did anybody ever tell
you that that's a lie?
Uh, no. Okay. So, there's this whole
kurfuffle here. So, we'll give you a
history lesson. Old man Suarez will give
you a history lesson. So, and around
like 2015, there was this whole
kurfuffle where like people were just
like worried their optimizers just
weren't working or whatever, right? And
the idea was that, hey, these are
massive non-convex optimization
landscapes and you're going to hit all
these local minima. So, there was all
this research on that and eventually
there was some fancy paper that came
along and said, "Hey, actually local
minima just don't exist." Um, right? And
the intuition for this is very simple.
If you flip a coin, heads or tails,
every single dimension, you flip a coin,
heads or tails. If they all come up
tails, then you're stuck in a local
minima,
right? Because you can go in one
direction or another. The derivative can
be up or it can be down. So they all
have to come up heads. Now, that's not
true because that models them as like
completely independent, but in practice,
it ends up being a good enough
explanation. So you know you just can't
get local minima because there's always
going to be some direction on which you
can improve. Now if you go from a
million dimensions down to a relatively
small number of dimensions you get local
minima again and you get non-convex
optimization. Okay. So this is why in
general we don't use dimensions that are
lower than like 128 and we at least use
neural nets that have more than 2,800
parameters.
Okay. It might not be that bad because
like in this case it's like okay
whatever it's 128 but it's just a
two-layer network but now you just don't
have any representation capacity. You
literally have one hidden layer. All
right. So you can represent one
nonlinearity is worth of
interestingness. And technically a
two-layer neural net can represent
anything but only if you make the hidden
dimension exponentially large. So that's
some academic [ __ ]
All right let's see. Let's see if we do
RNN
name.
Do this. Do this. What happens?
And not C. I literally trained that on
CPU. I didn't even notice the
difference.
Okay, I'm going to quickly swap over to
my phone in in hopes I can see this
stream. I'll be one second. Okay, so
we've got 130,000 more parameters. Well,
and it's not any slower, is it? No.
At least not on a 4090.
We do see some unstable shenanigans.
Doesn't seem like it's getting to full
salt.
Sometimes I don't I don't even use the
LSTM because of the memory like all the
time. Sometimes we just use it because
it has like a few extra nonlinearities.
So it's like eh better than nothing.
Yeah.
Come on, drone. You got this.
Do we know what max score is? It's just
5.0.
Oh, is 5.0 the best you can possibly do?
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, okay. Then yeah, we
should just set PF equal to score over
five and then we'll have a one zero
normalized metric.
Mhm. That's basically full solved.
So cool. All right. Boom. There we go.
It's doing it.
That's pretty decent.
Heck of a lot better than I could fly a
quadcopter.
solid.
All right.
If uh I suddenly disconnect, it's
because I have some electricians messing
with my power. I will have to go yell at
FYI. And I will reconnect on my phone.
Sure.
People keep messing with my power and
killing my runs. Drive me nuts.
Yeah.
All right. So, I wanted to check your
compute.
just try something real quick.
All right, that seems
okay.
This is a position independent encoding.
So the problem looks the same to it now
regardless of where the target is. Yeah.
Okay, that's already training faster.
Yeah,
sometimes the RL food is quite simple.
Yeah.
Okay, that's pretty crazy.
If I couldn't do this type of stuff,
people wouldn't stick around, right?
Yeah.
We were we were saying to some other
people the other day like back
back when um back when we were using gym
and trying to train drone, we were
operating our dorm room as like a data
center and like like all of our laptops
were just running at full speed for
multiple days and now Puffer Lib can
just do it in five minutes.
Hey, that is the uh that is the point.
Yeah,
I'm not spending the rest of my 20s here
working out of a warehouse for uh in the
middle of nowhere for no reason, right?
Cuz we're building some cool stuff.
So, that should be substantially easier
here.
still is going to cap about the same
because it's solved either way.
I don't know if this will mess it up to
be fair, but we will just fix this for
you.
Thank you.
probably doesn't mess anything up
because probably what happens initialize
them all the same but then because the
RNG is the like the RNG is in C is um I
believe it's process level so even
though you seed it it's like as soon as
it starts calling RNG functions from
different ends on the same process
probably desyncs anyways
Mhm. Right. I mean, you can see here
it's like that's 90% solved in less than
30 seconds. Yeah.
Oh.
[Music]
this this end should be faster than
this. You know, a million steps a second
is really any good here.
Let's see if it still trains though.
That's the question.
There you go. 3 mil. Whoa. Okay,
that's like more What did you just
change? I like looked away for half a
second. It was 3 million steps per
second. Uh, so it is I set back now is
eight. So you've got 8,000 total drones
or 81 8192 total drones. I bumped up the
mini batch size a little bit. Mhm. And
it looks like it still solves.
So, we just cut the training time down
to uh 35 seconds total.
Still solves. Yeah.
Well, we can just we'll leave you these
uh these parameters in.
Nice.
Just so you can see.
It does in fact work as I say.
Very nice.
35 second training to get a drone
policy.
a pretty cool looking one as well if I
if I do say so myself.
Yeah, it's like
very cool. Is there gravity?
Yep. Yeah, there is. Right. Okay. Yeah,
they like it looks like pretty dang
reasonable.
I mean, to do this in real life, you'd
need a pretty nippy drone, but I imagine
imagine you can get one.
That's actually something we were
considering looking at is like we could
if we were to do some hardware stuff.
Um, we could make our own drones that
would be ridiculously agile, just
basically impossible to control for a
human. And then we could RL them and we
have superhuman drones and then we're
funded infinitely
because that is a that would be a easy
nine figure contract.
Wow. Right. Okay. I mean, think about
it, right? Like it's like, hey, we have
superhumanly agile drones that are
autonomously controlled,
right? Yeah.
Just don't forget us. Okay. Yeah. Oh, of
course. Hey, I'm just I'm just thinking
about like, hey, where do I get contract
so I bring uh I get you guys involved
because we're going to need more people
on this stuff. I don't want to be doing
this is actually the one thing I don't
want to be doing is fiddling with the
damn the damn uh you know, fiddling with
the math all day to like make sure it's
to get it more and more realistic.
Yeah. because you know there might be
I'm sure that there are some additional
forces or some additional phenomena that
are not accounted for in this right yeah
there's like gyroscopic effects and
stuff that we didn't consider and it
wasn't too much more complicated to add
it
just like three lines
nothing
yeah
I think all like the planes and stuff
the physics for those is going to be
more of a mess but really the uh that
sim is more it's not that one that I
made this like the large scale battle
sim is more intended to show off like
tactics more than anything which uh the
policy in there is just some default
crap like it needs to be swept
and the obser can't even see each other
in that and they like already kind of
work. Mhm.
A look at that. That is solid.
I almost don't want to like put a
quadcopter model in because you're not
going to be able to tell as easily,
I guess. Yeah, we we found the colors
helped tell the orientation quite well.
I guess you could paint like the top of
it blue and the bottom of it red or
something.
Yeah. Yeah, that's a good idea. And that
would like kind of do it, but like you
still don't get the full
Yeah. Yours is like pretty nice. I think
it would probably be good. What we would
do is we should have it on a toggle. We
should have it like actually be a
quadcopter model, but then if you just
press shift or whatever, press tab, then
uh yeah, it comes up.
I do have a quadcopter model for you,
but I don't think it it probably is not
just super trivial to add in. You'd have
to
maybe it is.
I don't know. cuz you have to I don't
know how you do the angle cuz the way
you guys have it now it's just they're
spheres but I can show you the the model
that I have for this.
Mhm. Yeah, sure.
Oh, wait. Did I
No, I didn't get a quadcopter model.
It's like a different drone model. I
forgot. So, we would have to get one.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Cuz I I went with like
I got the sci-fi looking model, but we
could easily get one. All right. Okay.
Presumably there's loads on like the
Unity asset store and places. Yeah,
there are Turbo Squid everywhere.
I mean,
if you could do
Trying to think how hard a ring
collision
because basically if you just put rings
you you're like almost to a racing end.
Yeah. Yeah. That would be cool. Like the
racing ms are just a bunch of rings.
I think it's a little bit complicated
because what you basically you have to
do is you have to generate like
you have to is it like a bezier? You
have to generate like some sort of like
funky curve, right, that you use as the
track and then you place some rings like
on that path. Yeah. Yeah. I've worked
with Bezier curves before so that
shouldn't be too bad. Mhm. And then this
is perfect cuz like that's all the math
that I do not want to have to do. Okay.
This perfect. Yeah. Cuz like I don't
know if you seen the autonomous drone
like this like super human drone racing
RL
this stuff. Oh yeah. Yeah. A year ago,
right?
Did we read this paper? I think we did.
But like this stuff works. But like I
bet we could do stuff like this so much
better and so much more easily now with
the speed just that we have. Like you
know you know that even like this thing
they probably did like some crazy sim in
like Isaac or whatever that was super
pain to work with like cuz it's Eth
Zurich. They do a whole bunch. Is it is
this Ethurich?
H
is that I think it's a a Dutch
university. Okay. I'm not sure then. But
like you can just see like with built-in
randomization the level of simplicity
and speed you'd able you'd be able to do
this with now. And like this is not even
a complicated course. We could do way
harder stuff than this.
Yeah. These traces are pretty nice.
I'll think about how to do this. I think
you I' we've done trails before. You
just like render like some small shapes
or whatever. You just like have like a
buffer. Move the buffer over. It's like
the last 10.
Yeah. And then this is just like this,
right? This type of it looks way cooler
with the Yeah. I mean, that's literally
just moved the camera to first person
perspective, though.
Yeah. Like you can see what I was
talking about with the form factor
though. Like look at the look at the
turn radius on these. Even these things
they have a huge turn radius. Yeah.
Yeah. Imagine if it were just like
you know super jagged
and they have human pilots and then it's
you know they're uh
it's all these kids which is funny as
well.
It's like the same demographic is going
to be, you know, like the top at League
of Legends or whatever will be top at
drone racing. Yeah, it makes sense,
right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Looks fun. Yeah. I'd be awful at that.
We'll stick to the code.
Okay. Now, for the fun part, let's get
this onto the website for you
that All right. Now, the one thing is I
don't think you did the I don't think
you did the C network stuff, right?
Uh, no. All right, I'll show you how to
do that real quick. This is cool. I made
a thing to make it easy.
Cool.
Will it be on um like the the live
website today or will it be when Puffer
Free releases? When releases. Right.
Okay. Oh, and I'll need uh I'll have to
get both of you. We'll add both of you
to the uh the contributors section of
that right now as well so that I don't
forget to do it. Okay, cool.
What you do is you load in load in
weights like this.
Spencer, uh hey. Yeah, I'm on with the
drone guys in Discord now. Dude, they
did awesome work on this. Like, we
should actually chat about what we can
do with industry stuff. Like, this is
freaking cool.
Well, it's like it's like four months
now before we're back with uni work. So,
we're we're happy happy for whatever.
Let's get stuff.
Let's get some stuff going fast. Let me
just show Let me just show you this real
quick, Spencer. Like, look at this
thing. Look at how cool the dynamics of
this thing are.
Like, that actually looks like how a
drone would move.
Unlike my sim where I have like tons of
agents and it looks cool, but the
physics are jank as hell.
All right. So, let me show you how this
works. So what you do
huffer export
hopper drone.
So all this does is this just takes the
weights out of the pietorch network in
the order that they are listed and then
writes them to a binary file just like
numpy saves them and that format is
literally just like you know uh four
bytes for first weight float four bytes
for second that's all it is. Mhm. Okay.
So what we do is we get this number
which is the total number of weights
saved.
We uh we put this into here and this
will work for you know whatever n uh
so now we just we need to know
I didn't do continuous ah [ __ ] I didn't
do continuous action sampling though. Oh
I'm I'm going to try to I'm going to try
to hack it. But yeah I didn't do
continuous action sampling in uh in
this. So, the thing that I wanted to
show you though that's really cool,
right? Um,
the thing I wanted to show you that's
really cool is basically this thing.
This is pufferet.
This is
I don't know if I've mentioned but I
might have. Is this PyTorch and C? Yes,
this is PyTorch and Pure C. Yeah. So we
have a 700 line file that has some
common architectures has comms, linear
layers, LSTMs exactly matching the way
that it's written in PyTorch and tested.
So what you can do is you can take your
PyTorch weights, you can load them in,
you do it in C, you compile the web
assembly and then for small networks
they just run in your browser. Yeah,
that's very nice. Which is like if you
tried to run stuff and compile for your
browser before, it's a total nightmare.
So this was the easy way of doing it.
It's not that bad. There's only this
amount of code.
spell LSTM
the multi
rate.
Now this should load this in. We need to
know the ob size of 16. Is it 16? Yes.
16 I think. So yeah, what it says
that um and budget sizes budget size is
it
do not need to know.
I suppose we do need to know
that
sizes.
I believe that the way I should do this
is I should do this as
four and one. This will trick it. This
should be able to trick it into working
except
have
Oh no, because it doesn't save log
decoder log standard deviation.
Uh that is saved.
Okay, so there is going to be one
smallation
but aside from that
really want to get this.
Yeah, I Reset
All we have to do is figure out Yeah.
the change that will be needed
in order to make this viable.
Yep.
um is
if I were to guess,
I think it's going to be like this. Not
logistics. end of actions I equals
net
probably like
actor
output of I if that's how I've done it
yeah output
so we'll see if this becomes total
nightmare or not I forgot about the
thing if not we might just try to
discretise because I think That'll train
better. Anyways, I should I should have
a continuous thing. I don't want to keep
you guys here forever if that doesn't
work quickly. Well, that's fine. We're
we're unemployed and exams. I'm also
hopefully hopefully you see some cool
things because there are a bunch of
things around with this as well.
Yeah,
I got a message back. There's a guy on X
who like mentioned wanting to make a uh
a better one of these like it's like a C
pure C library. Um yeah, there's a lot
of weird crypto stuff these days, but
does have like some low-level people who
I could probably get to help.
Pretty nice.
This is
All
H it's idx
less than
thing.
This is probably an architecture
difference unfortunately.
Right. Okay. Let me see.
So this goes encode encode decode decode
value
code decode
value. Oh, hang on. This is the same. So
this should actually work.
Decoder log.
Uh according to this though we are
four weights off some maybe it didn't
actually save.
Wait. One agent 16
hidden size.
here. I thought we were just have nice
easy network. Oh, wait. You guys have a
custom network, don't you? Is it just
copy pasted or is it there be some
difference? I think so. H. The only
thing that might be different is the
hidden layer size, but other than that,
it would be Oh, what's your hidden layer
size?
Uh, I can't remember. I think it was
128. That's what ours is.
I'm seeing it save and it looks fine.
That's quite odd. Would the LSTM you
just added mess it up?
Uh, yes. But I
the LSTM I see it in like when I export
the the trained model I see the LSTM
here, right? Mhm.
Could
All right, we have most powerful weapon
is
actually setting break points in the
freaking code.
Okay, so this is the thing that kills it
right here.
I'm going to retrain this just in case
with our default policy.
Okay,
but we should do that anyways. like
there's not much point to have um
and if that doesn't work then we will
discretise and I will show you how to do
that so that at least there is something
we can be shown here
whatever we're going to do while it wait
while we wait for it to train to take so
long
C policy of terror for you. Thank you
very much. Yes, PR terform policy. Get
that on the web today as well.
I do have
you have a 4pm. Yes, I've got a 4pm. So,
I got 45 minutes. I'm chatting with a
robotics guy.
Tell this one other guy who's bugging
me.
Better not screw the generator like
making noise. They better not cut my
power.
He's so mad. 400 billion steps into an
experiment as well. Yeah,
that's 8,000 years worth of experience
is crazy.
Here's
our drone.
First of all, we'll check if the numbers
match.
Uh the numbers do match. So
Mhm.
Oh, you know why?
What?
There we go. My bad. Now it doesn't seem
to do anything.
So I believe it's
you output the mean.
Did you just output the action mean
directly?
I think for deterministic stuff. Yeah.
Normal. So this would just give you the
normal
sample.
Yeah,
I would think that that would work
correctly, right? Because like if you
just tell it, hey, you have a four-way
discrete output sampler.
And actually, oh, hang on. Now, now that
we fixed that error, I got to shift the
weights back, right?
Oh, yeah.
It's not exact, right? It's not exactly
there.
Maybe it's Do you think Do we think it's
relying on that sampling?
It could be relying on the uh on the
sampling
cuz I didn't Yeah, that's very possible.
That's very possible. Yeah, we we'd find
when you when you slow it right down, it
can sometimes hover like that presumably
because it it tends to not get that
close and not have already picked it up.
Uh, we will hack you a
continuous sampler real quick. It's not
that hard.
the drone follow the mouse.
I don't know how to program the dynamics
for that.
That's actually kind of hard as well
because it's 3D. If you could
Yeah. Yeah. Adrian submitted uh Tetris
and Freeway yesterday and the Tetris one
looks in particular really good.
I don't know if you've seen this.
Um I was actually really surprised by
how good this thing looked.
Play that. Oh yeah. I I also I had
another researcher, a colleague of mine
literally the same day ask me like,
"Hey, has anybody done like Tetris?" I
think it's a hard problem, you know,
like uh somebody's I think maybe people
have trained like it to clear 10 lines
or whatever and I basically said, "Yeah,
it's stupid because it's the end is
slow. I'm sure it'll work if the N4
slow." Actually, wait. Somebody's PR
this. We can check.
Wo and behold. No, it is. The thing is
it's literally it's a hard problem if
you're stuck with Atari training at a
thousand steps a second, but not like
this. Yeah. Yeah.
This looks sweet.
That's better than I play.
It's far better than I play. Yeah, I
don't think I have ever played. Uh you
you'll be able to play it here if you
just hold shift like this is now this is
me playing technically and uh uh my I'm
bad at my bad agent. You can take over.
It's doing the shift thing, but it's
refusing to listen to shift.
Left shift
and then
that we have to
Okay. So,
uh let's try to make sure that this is
the same first and then we'll add the
standard deviation.
And uh if this works and we decide that
actually does work and the other end
we're just weird then I will uh later
I'll make you guys just like a more
proper module. We don't have to deal
with this nonsense.
Cool. Cool.
That's a pain. I know.
Wait a guess.
I know this was like one of the first
things I did on buffer because it like
it let me run p your end to end on the
web and then that's kind of when I
started committing to doing all this
stuff in C
because it like makes a big difference
when you can actually talk through demos
on the
site.
Okay. Okay. So this is the same as
before where it can like drift but it
can get stuck I think.
Now we do your log
standard deviation sampling.
So what is it? Min
quote SPD
X
F
standard deviation of Y.
Uh now what do we do with brand n
random
I forget there's we don't have nice like
rand and see
right, we'll see if I dare uh crush this
thing.
Computer blows up and
That's actually kind of funny if this
was the problem.
Oh yeah,
that's so that's kind of funny that like
it actually depends on um the
randomness.
Mhm.
Yeah, we found that quite a lot with the
like the old old drone.
So I had to hack a couple things for you
for this, but um it does appear to work.
So we can put this on the website just
like that.
Uh we also do need to get rid of uh
these prints.
All right. So now the the magic here is
literally just change this from fast to
web.
Mhm.
And then um
single generator
see
this copy all that stuff. Uh, we do we
get a thumbnail.
That
cool.
And then all I have to do is add you
box.
You put drone.
Let's see. Right at the top, surely.
Not too far from it.
We'll do right after the really big
Sims.
Mhm. Cool.
And uh yeah, how should I list both of
you because I have to add you here and
to the contributors page.
Uh I guess
I'll go with full name, please. Sam,
turn up. Sam, find
have I just have Sam. How do I spell
last name? T U R N E R T for like Titan.
T U R N E R. Oh, Sam Turner. Yeah,
that's the one.
and Finlay. F I N L A Y
and then Sanders. S A N D E R S. That's
the one. Nice.
Perfect. 1080.
Our
preferred rescue act
works the best for everything.
Okay, so
two things we got to do. One is check
shows up
immediately just on the website. Nice.
It looks slower. Is that It does look
slower, doesn't it?
I can't imagine that this would be
low.
Is anything trading at the minute or
shouldn't be?
You check the other Ms.
Yeah. All that. Oh, but the drone itself
is Is there anything based on time?
Um, I don't think so. Not Not really.
No, nothing based on frame cuz like look
at this. This seems to be moving.
Like these stats seem to be updating at
a reasonable rate. Yeah.
Okay. That's a little thing. I do get
some lag on this end, but I get lag on
this end because I have a thousand
agents running. Yeah. Everything else
should be the the network
could be, but your net is pretty small.
Yeah, I guess I mean this is so this is
the same network basically but I trained
for you guys but running a thousand
agents.
Oh,
it's not lag. Yeah, it's there's
something with mcripting, right?
You know, it might be something with
like these continuous ends where like I
think your browser kind of just decides
to render stuff whenever. There might
have to be some sort of interpolation,
right?
Bit of a bummer. It's it's slower on
here. Let me think what how we can hack
this.
All right, let me get you onto the site
first and then out because there's also
you also get to go on this page.
I'll reverse it. I'll do it one order
one way and the other the other. That's
chill. Yeah, that's good. Nice.
Rocket Lander was No, Rocket Lander was
me attempting to hack on it and then
Kyle attempt Morganstein attempted to do
stuff and nobody finished it. Can you
show dronec again? Yeah, Adrian. Uh,
it's just in a while window not window
should close loop.
Why is it a linear cont?
Because it has continuous action. So, I
had to hack them a continuous action
space in C.
Do you think this thing is slow?
It shouldn't be, right? No, there's no
way this is slow.
easiest.
Oh, easiest fix for this. Hang on.
I just build it half a faster FPS. See
if it like
120 didn't fix it for me. Did you try
this?
I've tried everything that you'll think
of in the next few hours. Lovely.
Great.
It's weird because we definitely we have
ends where it's not a problem.
The whole web ecosystem is kind of just
broken. Uh web web people don't actually
know how to write code. Turns out I mean
you can just look at React and say
really these people know how to write
code? No, they don't.
So 120 doesn't seem to fix it at all.
Right.
It's just it's just frame rate capped it
looks like.
Yeah.
Banner.
All right. So,
um, band-aid patch
What are you looking for? Actually, here
what we can do is
I know what we're going to do to fix
this.
[Music]
Okay,
assuming the rendering is slow, we'll
just down sample the rendering to 30
while keeping the internals the same.
Mhm.
size issue. You mean a size issue?
So, that's super fast when I do it
locally, but
I don't know if it actually I don't know
if it's actually reloaded to this thing.
We'd have to do something to test if
it's actually been reloaded. Right.
Let's crank it like way the heck up.
Mhm.
So that is the uh
the ridiculous down sampled one. Yeah.
Can't tell if that's any faster.
Yeah.
Does seem slower, right? Yeah,
definitely.
So, I know that you can get this type of
stuff if you don't have put this in a Y
loop or whatever. You can screw it up.
Um, but the way it's supposed to work is
that the only difference with web versus
uh local your browser kind of just
decides when it's going to give you
compute time. Um,
think that there should be anything
super heavy though this end flag at all.
I mean, there's definitely a performance
factor gap between um like web and
normal, but like I if I do I should be
able to do your end at like 600 FPS
locally, no problem.
See if this
Yeah. So, this is this is fast drone.
Yeah.
This is like the type of this is the
type of drone that we would like to
create.
Right. This is the type of drone we
would like to create.
trying to fix this for you because it's
like it's such a length.
Yeah, it be nice if it's if it's full
speed.
So
yeah.
Yeah. I'm trying to think what it would
be that they have right like
Don't believe this is window ready for
sure
It's weird because I don't actually see
this on my ends like except for the uh
the ones where it's obviously going to
lag because the net is too slow.
Do we think it's text?
It very well could be. Like it could be
that the mcript and like the text is
just different.
You made some changes to Terraform C
dynamics to not be so aggressive. No, I
made changes to uh the controls in the C
so that it would not I made changes to
the controls and the uh the way that
actions are gotten from your presses. So
it doesn't set you to like the max Excel
instantly. I should not have changed the
C dynamics.
No, it is not pushed. But it should not
change your policy.
Okay. So this is the normal speed,
right?
Yep.
Still slow, isn't it?
Yeah. Yeah.
Like maddening.
Have a sleep or something? You don't
have like a sleep call anywhere?
No. Okay.
Got to love mcripton.
See rail mcript
didn't render slow.
This is uh
ridiculous.
Really good.
M script in bad. Ray good.
Actually, I think Rayb's the best piece
of software I've ever worked with.
Mhm.
really good
I'm trying to think if there's any any
calls that I see in here that I don't
use in my
my end.
You don't have any trace logs here that
like aren't on error paths. Yeah.
Uh, I think so. Yeah.
They're just for errors from slower than
brave. Yeah. But it shouldn't matter.
This thing should render 600 FPS if we
want it to.
Okay. So, the way you did it is
technically fine.
because you make
this.
This is actually all redundant, funny
enough.
Literally just delete that.
Okay.
How do I make your thing fast?
I mean the most likely thing I can think
of because like it still looked slow
even when we did um this like tick down
sampling right like even if I did this
like here if I do this locally this
should be zoom in right
that's like not even
yeah that should just be zooming but
then if I do this on web
If this is slow, what this implies is
that the actual environment code itself
is running too slowly to keep up. Right?
So look at this. The actual environment
code itself is running too slowly to
keep up. So basically that means that
something is compiling just garbage on
web specifically for some dumb reason.
Right. Awesome.
which is I know really really fun to
figure out.
Got one more idea and then I got to
figure out meeting. Um yeah,
it's kind of reaching a bit but
sometimes generated like a massive build
or something.
Yeah. No, it's the
end of dynamics themselves somehow
are not being called um frequently
enough,
right? Super weird. Like you see, and
it's it's weird because like your end
run super fast.
Yeah.
This there's like no memor allocation
for your own paternian logic which is
fine.
Not a single thing in here. weird.
That's just rough.
It's implied that it is the
step function.
Mhm.
Could it be all the the the runiffs, the
random floats?
I don't see why it would be. But
what? Like you think it doesn't handle
inline keyword correctly or something?
That didn't.
We'll try it real quick.
This is what we'll do.
[Music]
do anything. That's weird.
There is I have been getting these WebGL
errors lately.
I wonder if there is some weird thing
happening.
Yeah. Um
base RIB installed though. That's super
obnoxious.
I mean, we can technically solve it just
by jacking up this of this a little bit.
Retrain with that.
Um I will leave it to you to figure out
what how you'd like me to deal with
this. The the source thing I we'll
figure it out eventually. It's just like
I don't know what the heck is wrong with
it,
right? Yeah, fair enough. We can have a
look at it tomorrow at some point. Yeah,
I've kind of shown you the whole
process. Why does this pop?
Uh why why are we not
Come on. How did I How did I do that?
I didn't change anything, did I? I What
was the last thing I even did?
Oh.
Uh, I somehow undid this change. Oh,
okay. Okay, we're good. So, this it
still runs at least.
Okay, let's get this onto the
get these fixes into this. So because I
added this end and I didn't commit
Nice. Okay. So, yeah, here it is on the
site. Go to the homepage
listed there.
Awesome. All the uh the contributors.
It's quite a list at this point. And
then we'll have full here for now.
Figure out some fun ways to jazz this
up. Maybe it's just the quad quadcopter
or whatever. Yeah. Um and yeah, there
will be much more much more drone stuff
going forward. So I think we'll
you guys are free to play around with
multi-agent if you want. Um it really
would not be hard at all to do. Um, I
mean you could literally retrofit
either the physics of your end to any of
our MS or our multi- aent into any of
yours. Uh, there is so if you go find
this HTML, it's in the puffer.ai repo
under the dev branch. It's just ocean
html. So there these docs are way better
than what's on 20. Um, okay. And it has
like definitely have a look at that. It
has this this ray li style cheat sheet
and then it has examples. But then the
main thing is it has this little guide
on writing M which you probably know
most of it's got these checks but uh it
takes you through basically
the reference end which is target. I
built this thing as a commented
example to make it really easy to build
multi stuff. So this is like a trains in
30 seconds simple as possible multi-
aent fun and
um and like the dynamics of this
basically you add like 50 lines or maybe
100 lines max to this and you get this
great
take a look at that. Thanks guys. I will
get to meeting this is an awesome end
and I look forward to doing more drone
stuff with y'all. Amazing. Awesome.
Thank you so much, Joseph. Bye. Thank
you.
That was fun. All right. I am going to
head out to meeting. I will be back
afterwards probably for
We'll see if I come back before dinner
or after dinner. I might just take the
time to like go figure out who I'm going
to hire for the uh Upwork thing before
dinner or I might just come back and
hang out and record all the videos that
I need to do. Um, thanks for tuning in.
If you're interested in my work
generally and you want to get involved
just like these folks have, huffer.ai
for all the things.
Link to the discord. You can start the
GitHub to help us out. Really helps us
out for free. And um other than that you
can follow me on X